I think we get so scared of the big
feelings that we want to fix them and
like we're chasing them yes I was
literally chasing her and then we're in
what the message is like we are afraid
of feelings and feelings aren't
dangerous being able to regulate
ourselves as the adults and say okay I'm
not being chased by a bear my daughter
is not being chased by a bear meaning
it's not an emergency it's a feeling
which is an evolutionary response
totally and it makes sense you would
have it and it makes sense you want to
make sure that your child is happy but
we need our kids to know how to dress
for the weather and not try to like
control the weather because we can't so
better they understand how to have the
feelings and that they are survivable
and that we are not shaken